hey everyone looks like we have deadpool
finally in
the mcu i'm no john bailey but you know
who is john bailey
john bailey epic voice guy yesterday he
was
actually in vancity reynolds's video
yesterday it's just him and ryan
reynolds he's a real sweetheart that
john bailey
he does his ryan reynolds impression at
the end of the video and i'm pretty sure
they like sped it up because we've heard
it like countless times
and it's pitch perfect and there's
something off about the pitch of it that
i was like i think this is sped up
regardless
i'm just so happy that he gotta do the
video and so guys go ahead check it out
show them some support
anywho deadpool and korg react they're
reacting to the free guy trailer this is
the first official
deadpool mcu thingamajig i am just so
happy that this is finally coming to
fruition even if it's done
to promote free guide and yeah after
doing the free guide trailer there's
probably going to be some music in here
that will force us
to have to probably post mute some stuff
after it's been uploaded because that's
how those companies work they wait till
it's public to claim
[Music]
daddy needs to express some rage
[Applause]
well hello there and what's up reaction
faction
it's deadpool don't forget to smash that
subscribe button and follow me on
patreon
last week you all really liked my
cruella trailer reaction video
where are the [ __ ] dogs so this week
i'll be reacting to a trailer for a
movie which i honestly thought
came out like a year ago free guy
apparently it's this august we also have
a guest reactor this week
korg who was not my first choice but
apparently everyone else was too busy
over on disney so good
say hello korg hello made of rocks thank
you for having me paul
sorry you're dead jesus christ
let's just pause for a second let
everyone comment first or this trailer
gives away too much or ryan reynolds is
just me which is super insulting by the
way
god i love her so much oh i hope they
don't fridge her
what's fridging uh well it's the
practice of killing off or hurting a
female character in order to motivate or
torture the main character also known as
deadpool 2.
thank you for asking we call that
bridging
everybody we got deadpool
and corey guys situation more than that
put these on
okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something it's about your glasses
the glass trigger
any thoughts on our villain korg uh
looks like he's got four
arms and the two lower ones they've got
gloves on
i like them you have a disney plush show
don't you face
oh god trademark that's right
i mean that nothing you do matters i
know this world
look at him go that little blue shirt oh
his face is so punchable next guy i'm
going to be a great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity
off you go this whole good guy routine
is ruining the game
oh terminator let's take a whitey t
he seems quite nice actually
awesome awesome rabbit
wow maybe this is the live-action
thumper we all haven't been waiting for
[Music]
no
[Applause]
oh gorgeous i wouldn't do it
okay this looks fun in a in the last
days of
fox fire sale kind of way not sure if it
was worth diverting canadian
cumberbatch's little mind away from my
next movie
or you know what i'm gonna give it uh
i'll give it four out of five avocados
of course
nice i was raised by avocados oh my god
just kill me now
i was raised by avocados
explained so many tips on uh getting
into the mcu there cork
uh have a dream uh chase it
lose that dream just sabotage all sorts
of happiness
in pursuit of that dream climb up to the
peaks of that mountain
and when you get to the top land at the
bottom and realize you're never going to
achieve that dream
and at that point check your emails
maybe you'll get something from your
agent saying
marvel wants to talk yeah i prefer dark
world
what a great first way to kick things
off only
ryan reynolds deadpool can get away with
marketing his other moves like using the
mcu
as a means to market a completely
different movie and you're like
it's fine you know it totally works and
it makes me want to see
free guy more so mission accomplice yeah
that's what i mean there's something
kind of weird at that
because of deadpool's meta nature all
the jokes that he was making he's making
fun of the fact of what he's doing he's
making fun of reactors
he's making fun of the industry he's
making fun of the fox disney merger he's
making fun of marvel
and he's making fun of the three guys
ryan reynolds himself compose it into a
big
joke along with like the the great
editing involved and he got you tiger yt
i forgot taiko ytd's in free guy
yeah i think it makes a lot more sense
that they had taekwondo appears
it seems like such a deadpool thing for
the first time you're gonna see ryan
reynolds doing something as deadpool
mcu related that you're gonna have him
be alongside korg
it doesn't seem like the first pick but
it makes sense
based off the personalities yeah well i
mean we've seen already korg and his
cohorts just like hanging out playing
video games with thor so if anyone's
gonna engage with
you know new age media it's probably
gonna be him
one of his buds so yeah like they make a
surprisingly perfect little back and
forth duo because they both have a
certain good nature but korg is so
soft-spoken and sort of dear and so like
it's a perfect contrast to ryan reynolds
even though they're perfectly both like
absurd but in
completely opposite directions and then
there's so much associated with cork too
is like that's taiko ytd
with deadpool that's ryan reynolds you
know sometimes you see
just the characters at other times you
see the actors in the role these are two
characters that you're perfectly okay
with and you love the fact that it's
those actors in there
you know what i mean you like being
aware that it's them they're both
masters of comedy yet they're both not
comedians yeah and so to have them there
makes you go oh you know i never even
thought about a coring and deadpool
crossover but it would be kind of cool
to say that we could do a movie
or something together or have court be a
main supporting character in some
fashion like it
works especially from what's been
pre-established the last two deadpool
movies and it also works in conjunction
with pro when you're free guy
yeah dead cork let's greenlight it i
love this i really did love this and it
just got me that much more excited that
deadpool is actually going to be
officially arriving in the mcu
absolutely and ryan reynolds called
himself
out for always being dead i love that
line that was such a great lie because
that's what people are
constantly said about this he's just
playing himself all the time
he's just riding rounds and ryan rose's
deadpool all right guys well leave your
thoughts down below did you enjoy it as
much as we did subscribe
click that bell hit that like button
last but not least
panda mcjones i can't do the ryan
reynolds voice as good as greg can but
if there's anybody at our patreon who i
could see in one of these reaction
videos
with ryan reynolds trading riffs and
probably be you
i don't know why i've never heard your
voice but for some reason i could see
you being a korg
type of person you know maybe a little
soft-spoken but also
very much a sly devil korg gets a good
jab in there sometimes and i feel like
you would as well plus i mean seeing you
on the couch may be reacting to a little
olivia rodrigo
i'm just gonna assume that you like no
other music than that
so hey man keep on rocking in the free
world
keep on being the pandemic of love
and joy and good will and nature that
you are and we will catch you
on the next video next shout out next
month thank you for all your love and
support and uh
be well all right let's do this john